Шотландці пишаються своїм віскі, німці – пивом. А болгари?
Вони пишаються своєю горілкою – ракією.
Особливо – домашнього приготування.
Чимало болгар самі переганяють ракію.
На винокурні «Дідусь Пламен» робота кипить.
У цьому регіоні Болгарії ракію виготовляють переважно з винограду.
Ми збираємо власний виноград або купуємо його і робимо горілку.
Цукру додаємо небагато, щоби потім голова не боліла.
Я щороку жену ракію, бо полюбляю її пити.
У Болгарії домашня ракія має давню історію,
яка почалася ще в 11 столітті.
Мій дід, мій батько, всі робили горілку самостійно.
Ми сьогодні продовжуємо цю традицію.
Для цього є й економічна підстава:
якби ми заробляли стільки, скільки західні європейці, ми певно, пили би віскі.
А так ми змушені пити традиційну ракію.
Перед вступом до ЄС саморобна горілка була дешевшою.
Після 2007 – запровадили новий податок.
Виробництво скоротилося.
Люди виходили на мітинги до стін парламенту – проти змін.
Це був напад на нашу ракію.
Тепер вона подорожчала.
Привід для невдоволення є й тепер: через головування Болгарії в ЄС у першій половині 2018го
порції ракії на офіційних прийомах стануть меншими.
Роками ми тут пили ракію з німцями.
Уже після ста грам, вони лежали під столами.
Тепер болгарам доведеться переходити на західні стандарти:
принаймні на офіційних заходах у рамках головування країни в ЄС
закордонним гостям подаватимуть маленьку порцію ракії -
не 50т, а 25 мілілітрів.